no one expects a programmer to get work
done without access to a computer but
there are many companies that expect
programmers to get work done without
access to their mind hey
interruptions are the top productivity
killer for most developers
developers can't easily go back to where
they were right before an interruption
they need to get into the mindset for
development and then slowly trace back
to where they left off sometimes this
can take more than half an hour
more interruptions lead to more
frustration which in turn leads to less
quality work and higher number of bugs
but what about meetings
the only difference between a meeting
and an interruption is that a meeting is
a planned interruption which makes it
even worse
developers can't progress on a task if
they know that they will have an
interruption while working on it
so if they have a meeting in one or two
hours they will not be able to progress
on anything as most engineering tasks
take more time
all managers want their employees to be
more productive to collaborate more
energetically and work more efficiently
but in pursuit of productivity goals
many managers start to micromanage their
employees
they think close examination of a direct
report's work will improve it
sure such scrutiny might reveal
opportunities for improvement processes
a developer could streamline shortcuts
he's taking that undermined quality and
shortcuts he's not taking that he should
but trend this path too often and any
gains realized from process improvements
will be offset by the effects of
disengagement
what is disengagement
fundamentally it is a state of distance
from one's work
a disengaged employee puts in time but
little else and his apathy affects not
only his own productivity but that of
his colleagues
because a consistent pattern of
micromanagement tells an employee you
don't trust his work or his judgment it
is a major factor in triggering
disengagement
vagueness is another productivity killer
for any developer
there are many ways to illustrate
vagueness
for example a developer might receive a
bug report with insufficient information
to reproduce it but with a demanding
statement
it is broken fix the bug immediately
another example of vagueness is unclear
specification on a feature
when a developer receives unclear
feature requirements he will start
implementing what feels right to him
which might not be what a product
manager intended in the first place
when the feature is shipped it creates
friction in the team and the developer
has to start all over again
unclear prioritization also belongs in
this category
a developer might decide to work on a
task that might not be of top priority
while ignoring more urgent tasks
this creates unnecessary friction and
frustration in the team which eventually
hurts developers productivity
this might seem strange to
non-programmers but the environment in
which developers work has an important
impact on their activities as well as
productivity
for instance having some white noise
such as loud ac or cars passing by helps
developers stay in the flow and focus
better
that is why so many of developers put
headsets on
tuning out of your immediate
surroundings has been shown to increase
focus on internal thinking processes
similarly if the workspace is designed
to have as much motion as possible that
won't help them focus
or having the desktop computer screens
oriented in such a way that they are
highly visible to the managers well that
creates some extra stress and even more
opportunities to be interrupted
hey
scope creep is another productivity
killer for developers for any project to
succeed a project team needs a clearly
defined and agreed upon scope
everyone involved should know what will
be built and what is needed to get there
however when things are not properly
defined the project ends up in a scope
creep state
scope creep in project management refers
to uncontrolled changes in a project's
scope
you see change is inevitable in business
and in life
and every project will face moments when
you need to reassess what you're
building and potentially adjust course
but if these moments aren't handled
properly scope creep can come in in
balloon budgets kill collaboration and
send even the best laid plans crashing
into the rocks it turns relatively
simple requests into horribly complex
and time-consuming monsters
and most of the time it happens during
active development
all of this has a negative effect on
developers productivity
inadequate product development process
might also negatively impact developers
productivity
the product development process
encompasses all steps needed to take a
product from concept to market
availability
this includes identifying a market need
researching the competitive landscape
conceptualizing a solution developing a
product roadmap building a minimum
viable product etc
if a product team defines its project
priorities and product roadmap without
ever validating the interest of the
corresponding features through customer
feedback or any other means and the
developers see that most features are
eventually just not used they will feel
that what they do is useless and will
lose their motivation
we all want to feel impactful and that
may be even more important to developers
therefore if a product development
process is inadequate the development
team's productivity will eventually
suffer
unreasonable product development and
delivery deadlines often result in
developers frustration and lead to lower
productivity some product managers have
the tendency to ask developers for
estimates then push them to lower those
estimates as much as possible and then
magically consider them as deadlines
managers might even share those
deadlines with the upper management
since the developers agreed and
committed to those estimates
not surprisingly developers feel that
they are being held accountable against
unreasonably tight deadlines which in
turn creates tension and an inability to
focus
time pressures induced by unreasonable
development schedule can definitely be a
source of quality problems in product
development in general and lead to
developers productivity loss
hey
lack of psychological safety can also
lower developers productivity
google conducted a comprehensive
multi-year internal study to identify
the key factors that made their teams
more effective
psychological safety was far and away
the most important of the five dynamics
they found
so what happens when that all-important
psychological safety is absent in a tech
team
people become afraid to take risks and
innovate
they become more concerned with avoiding
mistakes than achieving big wins
this is an absolute killer of developer
productivity
developers tend to be naturally curious
independent creative and inventive
when you take away their autonomy they
feel cramped and demotivated when you
let them relax and figure out things on
their own they blossom and work magic
in a well-functioning developer team any
team member should be able to go out on
a limb and suggest radical ideas without
fear of being ridiculed
hey
disregarding refactoring can also lower
developers productivity especially in
the long run
when a development team does not
prioritize refactoring it ends up with a
technical debt which will inevitably
lead to low product quality
technical debt is a deliberate decision
to implement not the best solution or
right not the best code to release
software faster
taking on some technical debt is
inevitable and can increase speed in
software development in the short run
however in the long run it contributes
to system complexity which slows the
developers down
non-programmers who are responsible for
product development often underestimate
the loss of productivity and are tempted
to always move forward and that becomes
an issue
but if refactoring is never part of the
priorities it will not only impact
productivity but also product quality
developers also acknowledge that some of
the problems lie with themselves
some programmers are bad at
communicating and are not known for
thinking of feelings
they can latch on to some technical
argument like a pit bull locks onto a
leg bone
it doesn't matter if the team is going
to miss an important deadline or the
client request won't be delivered the
programmers get hung up on the technical
arguments
programmers can often filter out each
other's idiosyncrasies but teams can
fail when programmers knock heads
it is common for two people with
different views on various technical
topics such as programming paradigms or
architectural patterns to end up on the
same team
decisions become referendums on
everything these programmers have held
dear which inevitably leads to lower
productivity
if you found this video useful i would
appreciate it if you smash the like
button
also make sure to subscribe to the
coding tech channel and click on the
notification bell